[موسيقى]
عشرات الشهداء
بثت الرعب وصدمت العالم الحادي والعشرون
من اب اغسطس 2013 كان ذلك يوم الهجوم
الكيميائي في غوطه دمشق
الجوع والمحاصرون كانوا على موعد مع
صواريخ محمله بغاز السارين وزاره كادت ان
تتسبب في تدخل عسكري غربي
[موسيقى]
صواريخ لا تحدث صوتا بعد انفجارها ولا
تخلف اضرارا في المباني لكنها اشد من ذلك
وضعه تخنيق الانفاس وتدمر الاعصاب اكثر من
1400 شخص مات اختي ناقل اغلبهم من النساء
والاطفال وكبار السن اما الناجون فاصيبوا
باعراض لم يتعامل الاطباء في مشاف
الميدانيه معها من قبل
ان شاء الله
اللي ضربني
حجمه جاءت بعد ايام من تصريح للرئيس
السوري عن عدم استثنائه اي وسيله يمكن ان
تخرج نظامها من الازمه وتزامنت مع وصول
بعثه المفتشين دوليين الى دمشق اثر الهجوم
هدد الرئيس الامريكي السابق باراك اوباما
بتوجيه ضربه عسكريه لنظام السوري واستنفرت
حينها السفن الحربيه الامريكيه وكاد
الهجوم ان يرتد على نظام السوري ويخنقه
قررت ان على الولايات المتحده ان تقوم
بعمل عسكري ضد اهداف تابعه للنظام السوري
لكن الاسد استطاع ان ينزع فتيل الغضب
الامريكي والدولي بعد اعلان رغبته في
تسليم ترسانته الكيميائيه الضخمه
خطوه ربما اغلقت خلافه مرحليا ولم ينال
المجرم عقابه بل عاد استخدام السلاح
الكيميائي بعدها عشرات المرات لكن ذلك لم
يمح من الذاكره اثار جريمه وحشيه راح
ضحيتها عائلات باكملها وما زال الناجون
منها يعانون حتى يومنا هذا
واربع اولاد
اثنين قلبه يا رب
يحرق قلبه مثل ما احرق قلبي